capitol building in washington dc we are
now less than two months away from the
first primaries in this this year's
high-stakes midterm elections which will
determine who controls congress and in
many states there are battles over not
who to vote for but how to vote and
those battles are only intensifying it
o'keefe shows us now how officials in
the battleground state of michigan are
preparing for this high-stakes election
fight to come
[Applause]
this was the scene in detroit the day
after the 2020 elections supporters of
former president donald trump tried
stopping elections officials from
counting votes michigan democratic
secretary of state jocelyn benson
worries it'll happen again the 2020
election is indeed behind us but the war
over the future of our democracy
continues to escalate three in 10
americans and two-thirds of republicans
believe the 2020 election had widespread
fraud or irregularities
that high level of mistrust is fueling
groups like secure my vote a
republican-led group trying to use a
quirk in michigan's constitution to
change elections laws there's a great
deal of concern about absentee ballots
we need to do some stuff to tighten up
the way absentee ballots are handled
secure my votes plans would add new id
requirements for in-person and absentee
voting critics say the plan is misguided
and would make michigan the 20th state
to add new voting restrictions since
2020
and possibly on the ballot soon cbs news
has found reports of at least 31 people
across 19 states running for state and
federal office who were at january 6th
rallies in washington
six of them are in michigan including
john rocha who's running for the state
house
he's leading a push to conduct what he
calls a forensic audit of the 2020
election believing that trump won the
state he's one of 15 michigan gop
candidates endorsed by the former
president we want to make sure that what
happened truly did happen if anything
nefarious did happen that we go ahead
and rectify that and clear that up it is
the big lie that somehow the 2020
election was not accurate when indeed it
was but it's a bigger lie that somehow
our democracy is unsafe or not secure or
not worth participating in
important to remember dozens of courts
and hundreds of audits nationwide have
found no evidence of widespread election
fraud in 2020. also in michigan
republicans have been replacing some
local gop elections officials who
certified the 2020 results sparking
fears among democrats and nonpartisan
election experts about how ballot
counting might go later this year and in
the 2024 presidential election
tony
but as you point out ed no evidence
supporting election fraud in 2020 so you
have restrictions that are a solution in
search of a problem but they are moving
forward anyway ed thank you very much we
appreciate it i think they need to keep
making that point that there is no fraud
found yeah we need to understand and
people of both parties have looked for
it uh and not included there have been
commissions up and down and variety of
states you name it